plus de sel vite et d'éviter des ça
donne du velours à combloux à bien et
continue où il n'a pas tort pouvoir
qu'ils fassent tous la même taille
bordel fassent tous la même plutôt
taillé oui c'est au nom n'est parfait
classes avaient un parent sera doublé
par sion double porte sur un travail la
consistance dp s'il ajoute la crème sur
v la preuve tu te concentres sur ce
qu'il ya dans ses toiles jusqu'au départ
en salle tu l'as oreilles oui ça regarde
moi ok oui c'est compris des menaces au
poste oui j'ai mes salariés à ce fait
ils en paient leurs veuves le plat
principal de suite
mais voilà
salut mec qu'est ce qu'ils font lui anne
ou mariné aux arabes d'arnaud jeu de
citron et au yaourt merveille merci
écoutez monsieur jones je voulais vous
dire vous êtes vraiment admettre où j'ai
appris par coeur vos recettes est
revenue à héros ou un dieu je peux faire
la différence
tu bosses serait pour rien pour moi font
rien contre des repas oui je serai prêt
à faire ça si j'apprenais des trucs là
répond bien combien tu me paierais pour
bosser pour moi je me suis leur s enlise
par semaine de 100%
enfin sceptre secoué ton cv génial cet
agneau est vraiment une tuerie mais tu
manques d'arrogance et pour bosser dans
ma cuisine
il faut que tu apprennes être défendre
ok allez vous faire [ __ ]
dis le moi et bien au mieux de l'amour
qu'on porte à son prochain
adam jones à dole en gamme est devenue
l'un des endroits les plus branchés de
londres pour dîner en ville c'est qu'ils
disent l'un des endroits où l'on branché
qui le gère je veux pas que mon
restaurant soit un endroit pour dîner en
ville
je veux que mon restaurant procure jean
une espèce on devrait procurer des
orgasmes culinaire accord remonte ton
derniere orgasme disons intéressant il
faut absolument que j'évite de parler
cuisine avec vous en public
les gens mangent parce qu'ils ont faim
et moi je veux qu'ils oublient carrément
de manger c'est vraiment débile
la cuisine est l'expression de ce que
nous sommes et nous en sommes à deux
étoiles tous les deux c'est une critique
deux étoiles on peut continuer à faire
de la cuisine branché mais je veux
obliger les clients à paver à tirer la
langue
et pour y arriver j'ai besoin de toi
adam jones
merde alors le croyait mort et enterré
ça fait fermer beaucoup de bons
restaurants récemment je ne fais pas
fermer les bons restaurants mes papiers
font fermer les mauvais je veux que tu
m'aides à botter le cul de cette ville
insolente et arrogante de retour et je
vais cuisiner comme au bon vieux temps
avant qu réchauffe des bouts de poissons
dans des pochettes plastiques
quand j'ai une insomnie je fais la liste
de mes regrets
tu es l'un d'entre eux